[Music]
you got cure today sure you have you're
the owner you have here a cozy clothes
got that what did he know in black
I think you might wanna you know mom and
dad my black boyfriend will be coming up
this weekend I just don't want you to be
shocked that he's a black man if I never
see you like this before Brett
meet family take a road look go back all
boos you better come back ketchup they
have pants up to your damn stomach so
you guys coming up from the city
yeah I'm just heading up for the weekend
can I see your license please he wasn't
driving
I didn't ask who was driving I asked to
see his ID
call me Deena hungry my man so how long
is this been going on this thing
we hired Georgina and Walter to help
care for my parents and they died I
couldn't bear to let him go
do you smoke in front of my daughter
I'm gonna quit she could take care of
that for you how hypnosis I'm good
actually
I'm bad can be so look I go doing my
research apparently the whole bunch of
brothers been missing in this suburb
it's cool bro hey you're not scared of
this man could see no brother run here
[Music]
Chris was just telling me how he felt
much more comfortable with my being here
yeah sorry man roast keys no sink into
the floor
wait what see
[Music]
just tell me why people are getting
nervous
[Music]
[Music]